hi sharon hi everyone
how are you
good how are you
very good thanks okay back for season
three
um victoria how does it feel
feels good i hope people love the show
and ten how about you
yeah i'm definitely looking forward to
seeing the response you know because at
this point it's been a while and
um there's this whole pandemic that's
been happening
so i'm definitely interested to see how
it is that people react
nice okay well in this season joe and
love are going through some adjustments
having a fresh start living in the
suburbs with the white picket fence
newlyweds new baby
um how will their relationship evolve
this season victoria do you want to
start or pen whoever wants to go ahead
go ahead
i mean i think that they're kind of
forced to evolve
evolve change certainly in in different
ways um just as a product of
moving and
getting married and um
having a child you know is a huge
monumental shifts in their life
um
and i think it requires them to find
new ways to do what they do
to say it slightly all right what about
you penn what do you think will happen
with their relationship and how it will
evolve
i know what will happen yeah
what can you tell us okay what can you
tell us i guess yeah um
yeah i think like there's just more
pressure applied to their weak spots so
that means that
what we know and come to expect from
them we're gonna i mean you know even
though it's in the suburbs which
some might say is sleepier and more
domestic
um
they don't know that and they're pretty
extra in the suburbs they really
bring the city to the um
to the country
i mean having a child or bringing a
child into the world
um can be scary for anyone and joe
admittedly is the most scared he's ever
been how does becoming a father change
joe as a person
i mean
the thing about joe is that i don't know
that he's ever
really changing i mean although i guess
maybe it's human nature to change no
matter who you are so you know he's
he's definitely making a good go of it
but
and if any okay so like if anything was
going to change him surely it would be
fatherhood right
so i think by the end of the season
you're either going to see
i think you can say definitively that by
the end of the season you see how much
he is or isn't capable of change so you
will just simply have to tune in
well can he break his murderous cycle
i don't know
i don't know no
okay
all right well thank you so much i've
got a wrap here so i appreciate your
time